[موسيقى]
تخدير الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين
اعداء القاء القبض عليها
اليوم
[موسيقى]
القبض على الرئيس صدام حسين يوم 12 وتم
عرضه يوم 13
موضوع يعني اللي يشيع انه ضربه المنطقه
بالغازات المنومه موضوع ماله اصل ولا لا
صحه
نقل الي من محافظ صلاح الدين
الله يرحمها
لوائكم عبدالله جباره اكد لي انه من خلال
القوات الامريكيه احد القاده تحدثنا
والقائد هذا يشارك بعمليه الاعتقال اللي
يسموه الامريكان الفجر احمر
يقول بعد ان تم القاء القبض على الرئيس
يعني من المكان اللي كان فيه وهو ملجا
يعني محصن ضد القصف
الرئيس ما قبل يصعد يعني الامريكان
بالطائره البلاكوك يقول فنادوا على المفرز
الطبيه
وحقنوه ابره مخدره يعني ماده مخدره وصعد
طبعا معلومه لازم يعني اوضحها للمشاهد
الكريم انه الرئيس سبق وان تمت مداهمه هذا
المكان مرتين قبل هاي المداهمه والرئيس
كان في نفس نفس المكان ونجا يعني نجح من
الاعتقال لكن هذا هذه المره لانه كانت
وشايه
تم القاء بس هي حقيقه خدروا خدروا القوات
الامريكيه
ولكنه لم ينقل خارج العراق
اختلفت بعض الروايات اللي يشكك ان وجوده
لا نقل الى احد القواعد القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه خارج العراق
وانما كنا نقابله لما كنت اقابله بيوم
اللي اخبر الجانب الامريكي يعني اطلب منهم
تحريريا عن طريق الايميل والعنوان اللي
اعطوني اياه
بعدها بسبعه ايام الله تيجي الموافقه فكان
الشك انه اذا موجود داخل العراق ماكو داعي
لهاي المده طويله
[موسيقى]